J Rizzo why are men attracted to
strippers is that your question or do
you want to talk about strippers
oh hey Rich how you doing man good
hey great to hear you I was listening to
the uh the podcast earlier and I was
thinking about the whole Joe Hill thing
and I was like you know why is it
because she seemed kind of like a
promiscuous lady so why is it that we're
all like attracted to strippers and you
know with the promiscuousness of the
ladies it's like we can't get enough you
know what I mean
um well look like promiscuity is very
common today in our modern world men
indulge women indulge so it's just a
reality of the world that we live in
right like the chances of you
finding a pure virgin if you're over
like 25 or 30 is like next to Impossible
okay so women have experience yeah guys
have experience women are Beauty objects
they're also Beauty slash AKA sex
objects you know if you deal with Dr
Warren Farrell's writing right
um
so strippers are sex objects there's
they're stripping they're taking off
their clothes they're doing provocative
dances to uh songs
um you know it's gonna be boner inducing
City you know when you see them doing it
that's that's why they do it right so I
mean you're basically asking like you
know why do men drive cars fast well if
you give them a fast car they're gonna
rip it right you know you give them uh
you know you put them in a room with a
beautiful woman that's taken off for off
their clothes it's like flies to [__]
they're going to be all over that all
day long
um look men don't have a lot of
self-control
in their youth how old are you
well I'm currently 44 but this was back
like before my 30s you know I mean like
you'll notice that guys don't have a lot
of self self-control and then we reach a
point where it's like I don't know if
you've dealt with so many women or
you've had enough girlfriends or you've
been married and divorced or whatever it
happens to be but you reach a certain
point where women don't have any
Authority or power over you where you
can legit say no to a tent right if you
can get yourself to a point where you
can look at a 10
who might be manipulative who might be
destructive in your life you know for
example and you're just like no I'm good
that's a superpower
right and it takes guys a while to get
there it takes [__] it takes them
losing half their [__] in a divorce
being alienated from their kids it takes
some stupid choices it takes maybe
knocking up crazy it takes all kinds of
stuff it takes you know you come home
and there's a bunny boiling in your
stove top you know it takes weird [__]
for guys to get to you know the point
where they're just like I'm good I don't
need this right and that's a superpower
when you can get there
no I I got there you know because I was
thinking about it with the uh the
podcast like for the the 15 that I've
been with they were strippers I even I
even stupidly stupidly I married a
stripper oh man like she was a stripper
right most yes okay okay now we're now
we're getting to some story time like I
know guys that claim that they married a
hooker and they didn't know that they
were a hooker
why you did something so stupid
because I was a simp because you thought
you could change her you were playing
Captain Save A Hoe weren't you exactly
yes sir so how did that unfold for you
marrying the stripper it unfolded
um things were going okay yeah you know
and then we had one kid
oh you had a kid with a stripper and
then
one kid she cheated another kid she
cheated
she divorced me because like you know
like I said I was a simp did you ever
see that Seinfeld episode where he's
like you know how like you know you put
your hands up higher in your head and
like this is bad and like this is really
bad and this is like the worst sort of
thing
you go it's like dude you're telling me
the story you put two babies in a
stripper that cheated on you multiple
times all right yeah that's you know
where are you today now back in 2000 I
came into the manosphere into the red
pill and I was like oh my God
I was such a effing Loser yeah loser
okay I completely saw you know the
The Faults of my ways it was like you
know
hey it was all me it was all me it's my
fault I should not have done that from
day one I should not have done that but
I was so young like this is back when I
was 23. I'm 44 now yeah
yeah and
my God people like yourself like
yourself rich and people like Rolo they
have opened my eyes to what is really
going on and I thank you guys I mean
like thank you guys let's be honest like
somebody must have said something to you
one of your friends your family Jay
Rizzo she's a stripper like you sure
about this one like let's let's have a
conversation about this yeah my brother
my brother did but I didn't want to hear
it and I didn't want to hear it because
I was so infatuated and so like oh in
love oh I I'm in so in love I was a dork
a geek yeah
yeah yeah well like like Tate would say
I was just a [__] geek man
hindsight is always 20 20 isn't it yes
it is yeah
so guys
um I guess this is more of a share and
you know listen how old were you when
you got married uh 23. oh young too wow
how old was she
uh 19. she was 19. okay
well let that be a lesson fellas don't
date don't marry strippers
exactly
all right man you take care thanks I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out